I need a flight path
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full Star Wars andor episode 6 video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel I'm doing videos for
all the episodes be sure to subscribe to
get them careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments
but this was basically the actual Heist episode
like they've been talking about the highest for
the past couple of episodes this was the episode
where they actually pull it off I feel like they
waited like one episode too long to actually
pull off the heist like they should have done
it a little bit sooner than this but now we're
also halfway through the season so there's still
a lot more to happen but there are still a lot of
big characters like mod Mothman for instance who
aren't like core team Rebels like she's an ally to
the rebels but she isn't officially a part of the
Rebellion at least the way that you think of her
during the original trilogy there's also people
like bail organa the other major figures that were
responsible for helping the Rebellion get started
who just haven't shown up yet also really cool
connection to what's going on with Ahsoka Tano
during this part of the timeline she was also a
critical figure early on in the Rebellion under
the code name fulcrum she actually handled a lot
of the communications between Rebel cells so it'll
be interesting to see if there's any reference to
her in the background during the series I'm not
expecting it but it would be really cool we'll
probably get some genuine Ahsoka flashbacks to
earlier in her timeline like after the events of
Revenge of the Sith during the Ahsoka series but
most of that's going to take place during the
same timeline of the Mandalorian series much
later after the events of Return of the Jedi I'll
talk more about the Ahsoka series when we get some
more trailer footage for that but the actual
episode title is the I which is a reference to
the celestial phenomenon on the planet that's
sacred to all the locals the rebels use it as
cover for their mission to steal the payroll
and escape and when they're escaping when the
celestial event sort of converges in the sky like
the way that it looks makes it seem like an actual
physical eye that they're flying through they
said it the whole bit with nemik's new document
that he wrote called the role of mercenaries
in the galactic struggle for Freedom which is
meant to be a big question of morality like he's
trying to justify the use of mercenaries during
the Rebellion because of what they're doing and
because the Empire itself is is doing things
that are so much more terrible so throughout
the episode they want to show you that even
though they do do some terrible stuff they wind up
killing a lot of people they still aren't quite as
big a dirtbags as the Empire are they also want
to show you that they're this hodgepodge group of
people from all different parts of the Galaxy
like their core empire people who have either
left the Empire to join the Rebellion there are
people that are still part of the Empire working
with them to take it down from within and you
also have a lot of genuine dirt bags which we
find out Skeen is because he basically tries to
split the take with him like why don't we just
take off with all the money we could just split
it half and half you and me but at the end of the
day they don't want to throw all these Rebellion
characters under the bus that much they just want
to show you that it's a little more complicated
than you probably thought it was during the events
of the original trilogy the way they portrayed
it in the original movies like they're meant to
be committed to the cause but there are some lines
that they won't cross whereas the Empire wouldn't
even think twice about stuff like that we meet
a couple of the new Imperial characters at the
base this is commandant jayhold he's gorn's boss
his rank is kind of like senior superintendent
almost equivalent to a kernel and the other
important character here is Colonel peltegar
who's the Empire's engineer that's responsible
for actually building this much larger version
of the Imperial base destroying their sacred area
in the process also they try to tease a little bit
of the drama that's going on between the Imperial
characters too like the whole idea that jayhold
keeps talking about wanting to get off the planet
because most the people that actually work on the
planet view it as sort of a punishment like
they're relegated to duty on this planet and
they want to go anywhere else they could possibly
go so even the Imperials here want everything to
go as smooth as possible so they could potentially
either get promotions or just get transferred off
of the planet and just to make you feel better
about this whole morality question between the
Rebels the Empire characters they have jayhold
basically being the worst person imaginable
talking about the locals like they obviously do
not care about any of this we'll be done with all
this nonsense really soon anyway he insults them
he insults their culture they also imply that once
they actually do start building that new Imperial
base they're going to use the locals as cheap
labor to do it the emperor wound up enslaving a
lot of races and using them to actually construct
struck the Death Star so it's meant to be sort
of a parallel for that he does care a little bit
about his family it seems like but he's meant to
be a pretty typical type of Imperial officer like
somebody who just wants to uphold the status quo
and isn't really thinking about the common person
when they use the echo1 call sign throughout the
episode Han Solo Luke Skywalker the other Rebels
during Empire Strikes Back also used Echo
call signs to communicate with each other
I know buddy you read me we find out that barcona
used to be a stormtrooper and that's why he seems
like he's so ordered and by the numbers with
everything there's a lot of drama within the
group also because even though they never showed
it sintra had her whole family slaughtered by
Stormtroopers even though he wasn't part of
it like he didn't kill her family you still
get the idea it along with the reveal of Skeen
being a dirt back at the end of the episode it's
just meant to show you that they truly are like
a hodgepodge group of people from all different
sides of this conflict in the Galaxy just coming
together trying to get rid of the Empire and even
though that is a noble goal not all the people
doing it like in skeen's case are actual good
people love the look on goran's face as they all
pass by him he seems pretty pessimistic like he
expects most of them to die during this operation
velsartha and Sentra enter the base underwater we
haven't seen too many operations specifically
underwater outside of Obi-Wan Kenobi recently
and then during Phantom Menace obviously the whole
thing with the Dani Leader's comments about the
ghost having strong hands and long memories is
meant to be a metaphor or more for the events of
Return of the Jedi in the fall of the Empire but
during the actual episode they also use it as a
metaphor for their Heist like we're going to get
revenge on you very soon and they continue paying
out this whole morality question in tactics when
they have to deal with the commandant's family
like his wife and son are sitting here like
you don't feel that bad about the commandant
or peltag are dying like okay sure kill them
they're terrible people but like belsartha's
comment One path we win or everyone dies she's
totally committed like she actually means what
she says but they at least offer them an out like
okay you give us what we want everybody can live
even though a lot of people wind up dying anyway
so they don't want to completely throw these
Rebellion characters under the bus like they are
at least willing to avoid violence when they can
it's also meant to show you how committed most
of these early Rebellion characters are like
the beginning of the Rebellion most of these
characters thought that they would die at any
given moment the only real conflict here in the
eyes of the commandant is that if these Rebels are
successful in getting the payroll which obviously
they are any of the surviving officers at the base
would be severely disciplined and it'd be almost
as bad bad for them is that they'd actually been
killed they pay off the bid about cintra's bed
already being spoken for in an earlier episode
revealing that she's actually in a relationship
with Vel sartha not with one of the other dudes
like a lot of people suspected in the comments the
game that the guards are playing here is sabak the
celestial event the eye hits its peak and you
actually start to see it look like an actual eye
all the TIE fighter pilots taking off are at the
air base nearby that they kept referencing earlier
in the episode like don't touch those buttons
those are for the air base then the commandant
winds up having a heart attack from all the shock
when things go off the rails R.I.P it seems like
a mercy death for him like it could have been
way worse for him if the ISB had shown up and
he was still alive my only surprise here is that
they didn't get away with the entire payroll Hall
like they said they were trying to take the
entire payroll but you can see like there's
stacks and stacks that are still out there but
they say that they got away with about 80 million
worth of credits so it's still meant to be a lot
of money the ISB the Imperial Security Bureau is
who Dedra these other characters work for they're
the ones who get called in when stuff like this
goes down like we see at the end of the episode
like nobody's going home I want all the plans
about how we deal with this on my desk by midnight
they're the ones that do all the detective work in
the aftermath and try to track down the rebels
and if they do wind up finding them and move
to attack them and force that's when they would
call in the regular Imperial military characters
but like that's dedra's whole thing she's trying
to find the actual Rebellion that's the theory
that she's crafting in the background that nobody
else believed her about they pay off the title of
the episode the eye as they escape when they fly
through the path of the event which converging
looks like it's forming an actual physical eye
in all the little meteorites wind up taking care
of most of the pursuing Tie fighters I guess you
could liken this to Han Solo's escape through the
asteroid field when they go back to the ground and
you see all the locals enjoying watching the event
doing their regular ceremony the Imperials that
are with them seem like they have no idea what
just happened at the base like they're all taken
with the event like you would normally be if you
were just there having fun nemik winds up getting
his spine crushed by The Escape it doesn't kill
him but he does wind up down so rip they use this
to continue paying off the morality question and
the weird thing here is skein because he's the
one that argues to take them to the doctor but
I think the reason why he did that though wasn't
for the benefit of nemik like he wasn't trying to
save him he was probably just trying to divert
them to a place where it would have been easier
for him to take off with the gold but you get the
idea vel sartha does come off as a genuinely good
person like even though it seems like she wants
to let him die like no no we need to worry about
the mission she's willing to take into the doctor
and try to get him saved the doctor seems like a
new type of alien he doesn't look familiar but he
does have cybernetics that seems similar to lobot
cybernetics skis joke about luck is a callback
to Han Solo's joke to Obi-Wan Kenobi when he was
saying that he believed more in luck is a more
probable thing than the force was like he didn't
believe in the force controlling his Destiny kid
I've flown from one side of this galaxy to the
other I've seen a lot of strange stuff but I've
never seen anything to make me believe there's
one all-powerful force controlling everything
there's no energy field controls my destiny the
funny thing about that though is that by the time
of the sequel Trilogy he totally believed it like
oh yeah all that mumbo jumbo stuff yeah it's 100
true then if it wasn't clear Andor still doesn't
care about the Rebellion he only wants to find
his sister which is why he took off so quickly in
the episode but they also want to set up the idea
that he's a fundamentally good character who will
eventually believe in the Rebellion which is why
he kills Skeen because obviously he become a much
bigger problem to them in the future if he was
revealing this to him at this point but that's
whyandor gives back the kyber crystal like give
this back to luthen it belongs to him and it's
why they have him leave with nemiks' Manifesto so
to speak his document about the morality of the
Rebellion like he'll probably read it and slowly
come around on the idea of the Rebellion so that
by the events of Rogue one he is 100 team Rebels
back at the ISP predictably they rally all the
officers to plan the Empire's retaliation tracking
down the rebels in the missing money this also
serves as the proof that he had requested from
Dedra earlier before they pursued her plan I don't
think she was calling it a rebellion or Rebels or
anything like that she hadn't used those terms yet
but that's what she was talking about it sounds
like in next week's episode she'll go on the
attack and she might go back to ferrics because
she kept talking about ferrics and that's where
a lot of the big characters still are then we
finally see the Imperial Senate Monmouth talking
about this new fact-finding mission for Gorman
the whole thing with Gorman is that the Empire
perpetrated a whole bunch of atrocities there and
she's trying to pass an official motion that they
go find out what actually happened and the whole
idea here is that she starts looking around at her
fellow Senators is that none of them seem like
they care or they're listening or they're not
even there like most of the Senate seems like it's
not even in session that day like they didn't even
bother to show up one of these characters in the
background also seems kind of like a C-3PO Droid
but this isn't meant to be bail Organa from
Alderaan he would probably still be here like
he was actually a pretty good Senator I'm sure at
some point he'll show up and C-3PO and R2D2 belong
to him during this part of the timeline so if he
shows up they might show up we'll see but they
just showed up earlier in the timeline during the
Obi-Wan Kenobi Series so we don't know how much
they want them to specifically Cameo and all these
different Star Wars series the patch she's looking
at I think is just confirmation of the day's
attendance like oh nobody is here nobody cares
about this and I think this is meant to drive her
more in the path of the Rebellion like she's more
of an ally to them like she's helping them get
money but she's not core team Rebels right now
I think the idea is that by the end of the series
she'll be more active in the Rebellion like you
think of her when you think of mon mothma from
the original trilogy my other theory about that
too is that they might wind up killing off her
husband and her daughter is part of that too
like something terrible might wind up happening
to them in that drives her further towards the
rebellion in most of the cases the True Believers
that are part of the Rebellion lost someone close
to them and that's why they became Rebels back
at luthen's shop they mentioned the devaronians
saying that the language that's written on this
particular necklace has been lost to time and
it's meant to be a good example of why luthin
is doing what he's doing like what drove him
to become part of the Rebellion he's meant to
be the student of History like he reveres all
these ancient artifacts some of them seem sacred
to different cultures like they have the force
tablet from the mortise mural during Star Wars
Rebels which is a huge deal there's probably
a lot of other Jedi artifacts here too he has
what seems like the Starkiller armor and that's
just like a small part of it it just makes you
give you this idea that the Empire is basically
subjugating all these different cultures wiping
them out and stealing all their treasures and
that's a big reason why luthen is doing what he's
doing and they pay off the heist when the random
customer references it offhandedly just letting
him know that they were successful the whole idea
was episode 7 next week though is it is probably
mostly going to be about the ISB the Empire's
retaliation like what Dedra actually does when she
goes on the war path it seems like she's headed to
ferrics also Andor previously said that he would
return to fairing so it seems like a lot of these
characters will come back to pharynx one way or
the other you also have the idea that valsartha
and luthen have to decide what to actually do
with all that money not they have it but if you
spotted any other Easter eggs or references in
the episode that I didn't talk about in the video
just write them Below in the comments or if you
have any questions about what's actually going
on or where they're headed in the series my full
episode 7 video will post next week after they
release it make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here for my house of the dragon episode 9 video
and click here for my house of the dragon episode
8 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!